[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about goodbye
imagine in Vegas for 800 grand watch
check this out so Steve has already know
about this because I sent this picture
to them yesterday yeah it looked like
some crazy celebrity [ __ ] it's not 800
800 and there's all this is like a
baller bother mansion is a perspective
but you know what though 800 still like
to the rest of the the United sites
stool but for Ellie that's a [ __ ] ton of
money so what's gonna [ __ ] place is
this dude or la get a one-bedroom
one-bathroom you're right yeah it's half
a resort dude there's an apartment or I
guess they call it condos in Hawaii
all right that's being sold this right
next to Mario's place where she lives
right now it's a one-bed one-bath it's
five hundred thousand dollars dude our
house is like 7:30 that's what I'm
[ __ ] tragic dude I used to live like
by the Brady Bunch house and home opened
up right by their 1.1 million
one-bedroom one-bathroom well that's
because of the Brady Bunch house no
[ __ ]
who wants to let its like oh I could
live next to the Brady Bunch ah I do but
the brandy fans are dead man I want to
live in the full house house oh yeah
that's different that's happening every
time I Drive I'm like San Francisco
neighborhoods probably crazy about you
yeah
is it like where the peanut ladies
ladies ladies ladies
yeah I'm like I'm not crazy how does
that this show sounded like a strip club
to me it's like by the Painted Lady you
gotta show up whatever strip club what's
a Painted Ladies the the row of houses
that these shows you know and when
they're all having a picnic Oh
Thank You diem but someone new here you
know they're like triplexes did you know
that those are actually really big my
uncle lived in one of them yeah there's
like a whole bottom floor with the
kitchen and everything is whole middle
and in the house a lot farmhouse a lot
of people ready they divide it up and
then they they sell off the sections you
like the Gothic style yeah like the
Victorian yeah returns we plan there's a
shipment of those in Highland Park dude
and there's a bunch of Mexicans you'll
be okay that's creepy but I don't know I
like it has character no it's not
because it's beautiful I think there are
all beautiful houses but the fact that
I've seen too many scary movies with
that [ __ ] happen I'm like wall so
they're just old as [ __ ] and you got to
fix that [ __ ] man there's a bunch of men
on Midtown Sacramento
I didn't realize like how much of a pain
in the ass it is to buy a Victorian like
old home that hasn't been redone at all
like it's just there's so many [ __ ]
issues with it like even like these
contractors that you asked to fix that
they just go [ __ ] [ __ ] you know cause
it's supposed to do yeah tell me
yesterday was that the bigger tell me
you put your put your hand on a wall in
one of these houses and what does it do
so it's like it's like this office right
you go like this and watch over here the
rest of the building yeah exactly yeah
when you go all of these houses you go
to any Victorian house you gonna push on
it New Zealand yeah you hear that
there's a whole wall and you're like
okay yeah maybe not like okay what kind
of earthquakes is this gonna understand
I don't know yeah a lot of Sacramento
like Midtown homes are all Victorian
they are but they fix them up now you
know they actually did my intelligence
do it that's what I like I like that new
new new yeah the tech people took over a
lot of San Francisco homes and then they
take they get rid of the molding of the
actual character of the homes another
painting gray and it's so sad the paint
of grey they put that [ __ ] they have
a square cement oh yeah
the driveway and they put those little
pebbles between it you know I [ __ ]
hate those driveways that are square
cement and then there's just like a row
of grass in between yeah it looks like a
six-pack on the floor with grass around
yeah good but it doesn't and you don't
have to take care of the lawn that's
probably why oh you like your Papa green
and you don't just have this big slab of
just submit I like that so I'll see you
down all basketball I feel like that's
like a new thing cuz just they probably
put all the grass in the back because
that's just more maintenance for you
yeah like grass though cuz I see people
start doing the [ __ ] desert
landscapes in the face yeah I know every
house you look at you're like what's the
acres though I don't mind that's the
house look like house the weird thing is
like when you go into those old homes
can't grow sugar cane on so it was
important depending on the time right so
like if you go into these old Victorian
homes the living spaces are [ __ ] huge
I love that there's a dining space
there's a loud space is a big fireplace
but the rooms don't open floor plan
David open floor plan like this small
because you're not just supposed to stay
in your room all the time you're
supposed to come out into the living and
they didn't even invent a king-size bed
yet that's why so they only had like a
queen-size bed and then you try to put a
modern bed I was like five six yeah it
depends on the era on how their social
life was or like how family life was
like I think it was mid 70s and on where
the room started to get bigger because
George Washington was this tall the
rooms weren't small we're just getting
bigger
that's for sure that's true like George
Washington you should have to jump to
reach the door handle George wife is the
one that was bled to death
what does that let he was like bled to
death through his ankles or some [ __ ]
cuz I I think they were trying to cure
him from his disease you know back and
they they were to lead him the way to do
it was to sly somebody up and bleed them
out yeah
but that is it must have worked at some
point for the goddamn [ __ ] works
it's crazy let's keep doing this one I
would lie about my cold all the time oh
yeah you have a cold absolutely not no
thank you okay I'm good no I'm right the
[ __ ] beach yeah yeah well I was uh
I'm planning to move the Glendale what
this Friday so [ __ ] Glendale it's so
stupid the way they set it up because
all these luxury apartments it's dumb so
we have it's a 2-bed 2bath right but the
walk-in closets are as big as the
[ __ ] room which is [ __ ] stupid
that's what's good for a shoe collection
[ __ ] my shoe collection I want a bigger
room dude oh yeah all I can put is a bed
two nightstands and then put a TV on the
wall that's all there is room for doing
when me and Nikki were looking at places
we've we found this place it was really
great it was perfect but there wasn't an
office for me so but there was a walk-in
closet like in the dining room so Nikki
is all like tiny you could get a
computer in here I'm like why don't you
[ __ ] do it and then she knows me so
she's the office yeah you know she needs
an office too we both want an office as
part of our requirements this place is
perfect had everything she wanted to
kind of kitchens you wanted the layout
you want and then for you winning
well yeah [ __ ] that exactly and I sort
of him like yeah well I'd rather take
the hit than you of course so then she's
like we'll fine I'll take it
it'll be my office I'll be in the closet
and then of course I might all do the
[ __ ] closet thing but then but then
but then we're driving home and I like
file do the closet thing and like wait
we're still shopping for houses I'm not
gonna [ __ ] it just agree to the closet
thing and be excited about this this is
kinda lease yet yeah exactly but she was
totally down for me to like wake up in
the morning good morning honey and then
I walk into the closet and close the
door she says she's gonna take the
bullet she has to make sure that you
know that you should be [ __ ] grateful
for it yeah you know I mean I guess I'll
take the closet yeah then she goes and
she starts crying
no she shuts the closet and then she's
like she knows exactly what she's doing
she's making the [ __ ] out of me oh my
god here we go watching Harry Potter
with Casey and he's under the stairs
he's like I kind of had that kind of
thing oh my god listen during that time
about and this is before Harry Potter I
really love tiny and closed spaces like
I just wanted to be hugged by the room
Ozon that's called being suffocated I
liked it it's called been held hostage
was it was it like playing for it yeah
it was like having a fort like I really
liked just being hugged and so now you
feel safe guys Jesus is psychologically
revealing okay so when you watch taken
and that girl was screaming and crying
under the bed you're like lucky that's
stupid right so she watches that that
that movie were the were the cats he's
trapped in the coffin and she's like oh
that's really nice I actually wanted my
room to be smaller cuz I had a walk-in
closet where my twin size bed fit
perfectly and so I fixed it all up so it
felt like a fort but then I wanted it
even smaller so then all [ __ ] if I could
sleep in the in that little space under
the stairs so I slept there for a week
but it was too tiny you've got a twin
size bed in the closet in my walk-in
closet in my bedroom
that's pretty big yes picture you going
to like funerals and trying to jump into
the casket because it feels nice oh that
will [ __ ] freak me out the casket
you're like oh no my mom didn't let me
close the corner to go to sleep cuz
she's like you're gonna suffocate in
here but you don't hug me so the room
has to hurt my mom what was it enough
was it enough
yeah okay with Bobbili yesterday so he
does a lot of weird things and the man
has arguably slapped me in the face and
I've never been mad at him like I just
can't get mad at you just straight-up
slaps you just goes hot like that hard
like not hard it's just slap and Riaan
like play around slow and you know like
Ansel I think if it was any other person
that's like this type of thing like geez
left yeah
Oh like you're adorable slap yeah it
would be good Rhys you yeah like any
other person that would do that I would
think like don't [ __ ] touch my face
yeah yeah this Bobby Lee right and I
[ __ ] love that guy so he could
literally do whatever he wants to do he
did something actually I said that
pissed me off huh oh he graduated no
this is what he did and it was nothing
that he did to me it was just who is
this a person I know you're gonna sew
this [ __ ] we go to a coffee shop
right he sits down he has this croissant
he eats it he has this other cookie and
then there's no coffee and I thought you
gonna get a copy any us
I ordered the coffee but I think they
they forgot to give to me I was like you
guys what do I do
what'd I do what do you mean what do you
do you get up and you go get your coffee
he goes I don't accomplish like it's not
constant good Bobby it's it's your
coffee it's rightfully yours
you bought it go get a little frustrated
I think he's joking
and I'm like no no he said that hear me
they're both doing ours and so okay I'm
like I was like I'm gonna go up and I'm
get you a cup because no I want you to
do that because it's too confrontational
I was like I'm gonna do it
so he goes up he goes no I'm just gonna
buy a new coffee so he goes up he buys a
second copy right well they run out of
coffee so they look oh I only gave him
half a cup and then he goes I just
beautiful thing so he pays for the full
he pays for a half a cup of coffee for
two and he just takes it he goes all
right i'ma go get some [ __ ] what I
got so [ __ ] frustrating with them I'm
like go get your [ __ ] money back dude
never gonna give it to him for free and
he goes no I'm a paper full oh he's a
salesman's dream come on you know like
anti-diva
he's not most celebrities like once they
get to a certain level of Fame to demand
we [ __ ] before him he's like he never
even uses it do it exactly when Oprah's
getting free [ __ ] I'm like what the [ __ ]
what you need free [ __ ] what do you need
it for I think for her probably about
respect it's like oh really I'm [ __ ]
Oprah though she's like The Sims
character that put in the cheat code oh
yeah and you just put in your house
exact that's how she lives and this you
must be so bored with that because I got
bored when I use a cheat code
I never been more bored with that game
and they started killing when you have
everything you just put the stove in a
small little room and then you let them
burn I remember when I got I got to buy
my first like like flat-screen TV and I
was like that's nice but then when you
put in the G Cody who buy everything I
was like so bored after that he had a
valley his car and so when he went to go
get his car he didn't have change
he's so non-confrontational he doesn't
even want to ask change back from the
valet so he tipped the valet dude like
18 dollars because he just gave him a 20
it's not a confrontation it's not a
confrontation right give him the 20 he
doesn't want to ask for the change back
so he just gives him the full 20 tips a
jackboot wearing [ __ ] convertible he
has no shame in shooting on a [ __ ]
wall in public and grabbing strangers
dick right and showing strangers his
dick that's kind of confrontational yeah
but he can't ask for what I think it's
about the levees of power right so when
he's in a red room or something and he
knows that he's the guy in the room cuz
they're running for him he can grab on
dicks and things and and everyone's like
oh you know he's he's the hierarchy is
there you know I mean because at the end
of it I was just so [ __ ] dumbfounded
I just looked at the moment he we want
to [ __ ] hug hug you and he just doors
off when then he slap you in all of this
just like people want a coffee
David I like he literally sits down he
goes dude do we shoot in profit San
Diego my mentor Trent and he used to we
used to take to a game with each other
on stage and he started it every time
we're like we'd be at some dramatic
improv scene or something that's like
you know pretend romantic and he would
haul off and [ __ ] smack me as
or as he could and then I would like
enjoy sir I in the face across the face
like in the scene in the scene and then
it got to the point where it escalated
where I would jump in the air and smash
I'm using the [ __ ] momentum in [ __ ]
smack to the rap you daunted me like it
was like that you just walk off stage
and they just hear some [ __ ] [ __ ]
moving in a closet is a spear when he
wouldn't do that to anyone either so
it's like this weird thing where it's
like it's like we're buds in a way cuz
he loved he snacks the [ __ ] out of me I
smack the [ __ ] out of him this is weird
not really comfortable with this
brotherly thing yeah yeah brother loopy
but it's like I don't like you but I'm
just gonna slap you more I never liked
it and I always mean want to smack him
harder exactly yeah yeah big [ __ ]
heads know what he was gonna do he's
been he's just as big as me man oh he's
like okay we're both big so yeah yeah
instead of a bit it was like we do all
kinds of [ __ ] like that we just like do
spit-takes on each other what does that
mean we're like you do the water thing
and then somebody says a thing and then
you spit it out funny that's like the
game you know I purposely make sure to
spit on him he purposely make this about
me I don't think so you don't want to
watch The Improv you don't want to watch
him properly I just said I want to watch
you don't wanna watch them titty I like
improv on a screen or you're gonna be
there that's completely different mean
it isn't caption cast imagined they like
the only show that made Improv fun was
the who lines yeah anyway yeah improv
games are much more fun like improv
shows they're like a hit and miss it's
like 50% you might get a really good one
or the other half it just might be
really bad people yes so just try
recording that and see what happens with
it from a camera from like 10 feet away
it's just like this wide stage it's just
it doesn't capture it and it's funny cuz
that's how I like first got into improv
I was doing that kind of [ __ ] and scene
Diego and then I came to LA and I
started doing long-form improv and then
all long-form improv people view short
form improv people was being hacked oh
my god
like like a little battle well it's like
it's like oh we long for them we do more
like advance like longer scene there's
no prob yeah exactly it's not a lot of
props you do all the space work yourself
and then it's like we don't need all
that hack [ __ ] that you're not I want to
take both those groups that sit them
down together and say hey both of you or
losers nobody [ __ ] cares name the
most famous improviser right don't look
a lot of people when le I'd have no idea
who the [ __ ] del closes in close so
close I don't even know who that is the
guy who like founded the hole I thought
the the career path for them was MADtv
or SNL or students yeah so it's like
entry-level it's like you're the
receptionist in the office mmm
oh yeah sometimes yeah yeah it's a
different thing notes completely hella
different it's hella different but a lot
of there's a lot of crossover em yeah I
only know about the improv guys that
make you like Will Ferrell or like yeah
same here like Steve Carell like those
guys I would say almost all the dudes in
comedy at some point did in progress
stand there while all right Steve Carell
is improv like wild dude like it's just
so [ __ ] good did you see I I think it
was is his audition for the office and
he pretended to eat a [ __ ] muffin
mm-hmm like a muffin that was choking
him yeah and it was so [ __ ] good I
forgot that he wasn't actually eating a
muffin wow he's so [ __ ] good and it
was just so funny yeah I mean that was
his I did Will Ferrell's as an audition
where he's doing the get off the shed
bit and you seen that no just yelling at
this kid he's like get off the [ __ ]
shed he's like get off the [ __ ] he keeps
I'm trying to have a nice barbecue but
everybody's like he's like hey what do
you guys want you want some chicken
tenders okay great he's like yeah he's
like do you like barbecue on that he's
like the light sauce of medium so get
out the [ __ ] shed Cavitt
Dylan get off the [ __ ] shed like it's
great it's a great bit I said no doesn't
make me laugh anymore man like I feel
like the old cast members they just they
just brought something but the new cast
members I'm bringing I don't there's a
couple things going on I think that the
it's like when I was a kid and I watched
Conan O'Brien and my dad thought Carl
Brian saw hmm like I think that the
current
SNL stuff is for the kids like that
that's for the younger people oh yeah
yeah yeah consume that yeah we aged off
or made me laugh either I've always
liked MattyB in living color yeah I was
I mean I always liked Matt T be more but
S&L always had like it's like when I
watch South Park South Park to me I
didn't like all the episodes but there
were episodes that stuck out to me hard
oh I haven't had an SNL episode that
makes member they just have nine didn't
like nineteen I never missed us oh no I
never won oh that's how I was on MADtv
but I think I just kind of aged out of
the I mean I agree it doesn't make me
laugh anymore but but it's tough to say
that it's because they're not flying
he is from just kidding films I'll tell
you that we have remember the [ __ ]
ultra-beam yeah yeah yeah we with Ben
stantly did that [ __ ] first and then
months later yeah maybe even a year
later ultra v-neck they [ __ ] came out
with theirs and I was almost the exact
same and then it was a spa the Korean
spa Korean spa was that SNL that was
opponent Conan O'Brien was it just a
sketch of the Korean spa no no it was
even formatted it was like the format
was like kind of hyper same okay yeah
challenged each other at the spa we were
just like and they did the same exact
thing ah the writers are so uncreated I
did a whole thing called puppet cop
about a guy with a puppet partner cop
with the puppet partner and it's played
in the world where their puppets are
people and just kind of yeah yeah yeah
it was like a [ __ ] egg like one of
these puppets oh yeah yeah kind of there
was this a there was this a footlocker
commercial so I had this character that
I had a long time we called ball handles
and it was just this ridiculous
basketball carry yeah okay so basically
he's called ball handles because he just
really checks everybody the balls yeah
oh nice as a booklet and then they did
really well I got like like whatever
like I don't know ten million views on
Facebook and some [ __ ] like that
and then later on footlocker did a
commercial exactly like ball hand out
because everybody either tweeted me
tagged me in the video they're like eh
Congrats on writing this commercial and
I was like what do you mean I was like
did they use the ball handle and I saw
it it was almost they just tweaked the
little small things about it was like
frame for frame yeah and I was like what
in the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] dude it made me
[ __ ] man [ __ ]
writer out there is like this is a great
idea they don't need in copyright this
[ __ ] [ __ ] amateur didn't they [ __ ]
say hey look at this look at what I
wrote and in their pitching these
commercials and they think it's a great
idea they're profiting off of our
writing well I had a weird time with my
public option because it was like the
same kind of thing as the happy time
murders which came out later which bond
I guess really badly but then it's weird
because I kind of know the guy who wrote
happy time murder so you can't copied
you I know it's just a weird thing I'm
not even I it's just weird to be close
to somebody who who does the same kind
of thing that you did oh yes very
strange thing and I've had people
identify was it because sometimes it's
just a coincidence right first it's like
really the cot only the pitch the
concept but the format or like ever the
beats were the same or like look how
close it was it like jesse wellens in
case you nice that's blocks back in the
day i don't like i don't know all was it
like back in the day where like a d-trix
is sketches look just like ryan he goes
like that like that close it could be
that I also used to dart bit art showing
bit that Nathan for you ended up doing
and then I found out a couple people on
the writer staff actually used to be on
the maker staff with me so they probably
remember like a writers room with you
and then maybe you know because that
happens to cuz you know we do so much
pitches that they hear it and they think
it's their own idea well I also think
that when you're in a writers room and
you have to come up with an x amount of
ideas a week you just start littering
the page with things that you just have
on your head and then you don't know
what they're gonna pick and then
sometimes they pick that and then it's
like okay okay I forgot it with Steve's
or I choose to bring it
[Music]